alexis lacroix est ce que laurent
wauquiez dans cette grotte revenu dans
ses frontières s'il est élu président
des républicains pourra légitimement se
réclamer du gaullisme il a montré sur
guillaume qu'il est pris à tous c'est à
dire que recommande ir retourner en
urgence son petit buggy idéologique ça
n'a jamais gêné c'est un homme des
rodéos idéologique il faut quand même
rappeler qu'il a commencé dans la
démocratie chrétienne j'allais dire la
plus pâlichonnes et la plus pro
européenne celle que denis parfois à
juste titre critique dans le sillage de
jacques marot en coin et il est devenu
ensuite par disons ruptures successives
à ces rites quand même ouais mais il est
devenu disons un peu de manière
crescendo depuis la fin du sarkozysme et
il a faim aussi d'ailleurs des conseils
officiel de patrick buisson
il est devenu le tenant d'une ligne mais
surtout c'est la question c'était voilà
est-ce que par exemple on va dire que
laurent wauquiez et eurosceptique il a
écrit un livre pour dire qu'il fallait
reconstruire l'europe est ce que est ce
que quand ça il peut dire bah moi je
suis gaulliste autant que monsieur
solaire à vie alors bien naturellement
parce qu'en réalité l'euroscepticisme
c'est là qu'un si vous voulez ya une
difficulté pour les constructif et pour
dit on va dire au sens large
la libérale il est républicain incarné
par des personnes qui sont d'ailleurs
tout à fait respectable comme fabienne
keller vous les verrez citer les autres
de l'entrée de la difficulté c'est
catégorique non qu'ils soient pas des
balances du tout la difficulté c'est
qu'effectivement là je vous rejoins
historiquement il y à une ambiguïté dans
le gaullisme autant le gaullisme c'est
tendre la main à une france de gauche
pour bâtir un programme d'union
nationale ça c'est vrai donc ça va dans
le sens par le pardon mais ça va dans le
sens traces du malade du maquereau knees
et disons de l'idée macro nien du
rassemblement gaulliste que défend
aujourd'hui un solaire pour que des faux
ou que les fonds avec être atteint sans
le talent du centenaire jean thériault
lis je terminaux mais il y a dans le
goal is une priorité donnée à l'action
d'état et à la souveraineté nationale
qui rend l'appropriation sémantique du
gaullisme
demain par wauquiez par ses amis
buissonne is est possible et j'allais
dire d'une certaine manière aussi
crédible ce qui pose un problème
évidemment sémantique philosophique au
constructif
comment
démontrer à l'électorat de droite aux
personnes qui nous écoutent et qui sont
légitimement à la recherche en quelque
sorte de repère que la voie choisie par
laurent wauquiez n'est pas la bonne
et ben franchement bon courage ça va
être difficile à démontrer